i placed my hair up on the iron throne
and all the dragons roared as one
the weight of expectation for a tv show
doesn't come much heavier as the first
game of thrones prequel is about to
arrive on our screens highly anticipated
and reported to cost around 16 million
pounds per episode there's plenty riding
on this
throne's left a huge cultural footprint
and we're never going to be able to to
to lay the same one but we're trying to
do something original and something
new and something that feels like it's
it's our own
based on george r.r martin's
best-selling novels game of thrones
became arguably the biggest tv series
ever
no matter what viewers thought of that
ending it was really just the beginning
of what will be a huge franchise with
several spin-offs in the works it's a
model we're familiar with thanks to
marvel and to star wars and it means
there's endless opportunities for
prequels and sequels as long as viewers
remain loyal to the throne
and with off-the-scale production design
and a crew of 2 000 people it was always
going to be a challenge making this and
that's before you throw in a pandemic
i've got covered
i'm sorry i hope you're feeling okay
i mean listen what was already
complicated and hard was made more
complicated hard and we often thought to
ourselves
why on earth are we doing this right now
why can't we wait but the reality is is
you know uh
you have to find a way a woman would not
inherit the iron throne because that is
the order of things it may be a fantasy
series but a story about women taking
power feels particularly pertinent now
there's a woman looking to rule how do
you convince your electorate your male
subjects that you are not other how do
you do that and i feel like that's
it's kind of yeah i feel like that's a
fundamental question of the work which
is why we wanted to do it
the possibility of a female leader
backstabbing infighting this latest
installment from westeros seems perhaps
not far from westminster but will no
doubt keep audiences gripped claire
gregory sky news